all right welcome to my first video
bought a new laptop and I it's an HP
Pavilion db7 T so of course I've got the
media center remote with it quite a nice
room so um this into the little press
card slot on the side of the laptop
which I'm recording this on right now
and so I'm going to do a very very short
review of it obviously I can't show you
what it does on the screen because I'm
recording it on the laptop but um I'll
get into that later so here's the remote
itself I said it fits into the Express
card slot this right here that button
the green button opens up Windows Media
Center so that's that's what it does I
actually haven't used every single
button on this but I'll go through the
DVD button right next to the power
button so the power button turns off the
computer in the first place the entire
computer yeah so don't press that by
accident DVD button will play DVDs it'll
open up the DVD interface and walk you
through that not sure what the smart
like you can beef comments on this video
and tell me what the other buttons do so
um these on this line here is the media
control so your rewind your fast-forward
your play pause your stop channel up and
down for the TV and pardon the light
behind me by the way so this these right
here
will control everything else so if
you're going to scroll up and down
through pictures and you can hit the
okay button to select you can go
backwards one song or a forward one song
or they'll way around so that's to go
forward backwards in the clip or the
song and this button here has a small
letter I on it it's not very clear
but it basically brings up all the
things like the BlackBerry menu you
might have been familiar with brings up
all the options you
do with that particular piece of media
and the arrow on the other side it will
bring up it will just go back back one
step from where you were before like an
internet browser and finally at the
bottom of the remote is the volume
controls kind of shiny but that's the
volume up volume down and meat button um
all nails pretty handy I get 15 your
pocket quite easily as you can see I
began but it's pretty small leave
comments and subscribe thanks